sam first and foremost congratulations
on your life on everything your guys
freedom together how do you feel with
everything going on thanks man
everything's amazing we're so excited to
start a new chapter and everything's so
positive from here on out yeah we all
feel like that for you so we're happy to
see it um what can you tell us about
wedding planning what can you tell us
about bachelor party what can you tell
us about any of the fun stuff that goes
with spending the rest of your life
together i don't think we're going to
have a bachelor party tonight no man
that's the parties are in the past so no
that's a party but when i get the invite
i'll send you an invite as well i am
auditioning for best man i have one of
my best mans here but i think i'm going
to put together a real cool dance so i'm
auditioning for some time to get in
there listen if sam asked me to audition
we'll be sending you the tape look out
for it it's coming after you um what are
you looking most forward to this evening
here i just my love for cinema so much
so i'm really excited this is my first
time being at oscar event so i'm excited
to really just be here and you know meet
everyone and celebrate my love for
cinema yeah you know brandi carlisle
singing tonight are you excited about
that very much yeah
what have you guys talked about moving
anywhere special you and brittany buying
a house somewhere fantastic that we need
to know about yeah man everything's
going to be new from here on out so you
know all all the new stuff are in yeah
all right brother thank you so much
enjoy yourself sam thank you